hilfst du meine ganzen dings fans sagen
redet die quelle
ja ja ich habe deine ganzen fig bälle
was auch immer leute was geht hier ist
euer ghani und heute gibt es ein wenig
bett wars london zusammen mit xxx
ich würde aber sturm aber hey das geht
nicht zusammen
das teilt genau das loblied auf ein
nachbar von drüben möchten so eiskalt
als er sitzt hier so aber irgendwie habe
ich es an gelassen oder so ändern und
dann höchst so machst du alles aus ihrem
dann kommst du genau gegenüber von mir
ich finde finde es auch stark also schon
ein bisschen gelungen so dieses breite
masse anzusprechen weil ich mit ein
bisschen auch schon autos vorbeigefahren
das augen gehört hat man sowas ist total
surreal also das ist super witzig finde
es auch echt lustig sein weiß woher sie
kommen
naja dann frage ich mal dich früher aus
dem bett zu gucken würde ich jetzt hat
auch einen verein zu machen fest der
nicht nur fresse halten oder einfach mal
die fresse halten mich schon sehe
durchaus verlassen nsa und kokain ich
verkaufe das tracking kids ja ja ja ja
oh mann ich bin so des todes lsd kokain
ich verkaufe das crack an kids so ok
moritz ihr können zu wenig es eigentlich
wenig wahrscheinlich ich habe die leute
einfach erst mal ich will das jetzt
definitiv allemal wie die kirsche
eingibt und euch erstmal alle die davon
gehört hatte was mit wilhelm kramer zu
tun
ja das ist die härteste rapper aus
münchen apa das glaube ich dir jetzt
aber nicht es gibt es ist so dass sie es
gibt immer diese diese local rapper soll
diese richtig schlecht sind und dann ja
was schlecht ist sehr gute sache sagt er
dass sein bestes lied als wirklich alle
lieben chefsache lieder der politik kann
das nicht gut aber wenn er billig herbst
als willi klingt wie so ein österreicher
der verfolgung der hat früher auch mal
pizza verkauf bei uns in der schule
und glaubt man einiges wenn man nicht
von der hand zu weisen von der hand in
den mund
zuletzt war der hand 100
wo ich bin lebst du noch
ich habe mich nur gold wurden kann kein
silber ach komm geh doch ins web einfach
mist nach ghani auch nach khartum vor
der aufnahme bitte spiel nicht so gut
ich lebe ich hier schon zurück weil du
ja der größte oder auf der größe wie die
cash ich habe falsche prioritäten
gesetzt
so wie damals als ich entschieden habe
denn die armee zu gehen wird und genau
das war das wir planen jetzt der seite
des berges wurde das nachzumachen was
kann ich noch tun das natürlich
geschickt jetzt aber ich kann auch
einfach ein bisschen regen und dann
hinter der türkin hat so gar nicht
hacker mahnte hacker die gestellt dass
die face kann so tief war
das hat ein stück vieh auf mehreren
aufnahmen ich jetzt nach revanche
er kommt ja wenn man so zur hälfte
irgendwie da so raushängt aus der face
käme dann dann ist da weiß man jetzt ist
die revanche schon drin mobiler kleine
kleine der kleine show stehlen
die geschockte auch weil du mittels hast
ja mogis passiert aber mit doppelter
weil es war grad nur mehr bedingt weil
die mehr kann ich nicht so gut ich
dachte mir ich brauche mir war speichert
ist man wieder bei sturm ihr letztes mal
letzten da habe ich mal wieder auf
deinen charakter ist generell sage ich
dir etc ich habe auch keinen kanal
gestatten aber dieses duell ist weil
bisher anscheinend ich glaube dass eine
playlist also was davon
und das könnte auf jeden fall mal aus
checken aufstellen kann allerdings ist
natürlich in dem schreiben
und ganz ganz coolen da hat er mich aber
leider ziemlich korrekt und deshalb will
ich jetzt meine reform wir machen das
jetzt so lange jeden tag bis die familie
ich bin ich spiele doch auch gar nicht
so viel du kriegst du bist sowieso
besser als ich im pvp ja meist erdig
manager lee santana und aber davon nur
einen pvp musst du auch aber ich weiß
nicht ob ich besser ist also auf jeden
ich bin jetzt einzige womit man sich
übungen holen kann des streams aber ich
liebe auch schon seit monaten nicht mehr
also ich spiele in letzter zeit relativ
viel pvp einfach so wegen waren lust an
gefunden habe aber ich bin nicht sicher
gerade eben weil das ja keinen kaffee
aufeinandertreffen würden bestimmt ist
kein brustpanzer manchmal wird es auch
nicht angezeigt haben immer ein bisschen
angst hier und ich hatte gar keine
rüstung echt würde jeder so ehrlich kann
auch sein ich weiß wo das war dein skin
aber ich glaube das war's das nachsehen
rani nackt sehen wollte ich schon mal
weiter das 25.000 like sind dann zeige
ich mein fuß oder dass ein fuß aber nach
dem fuß meinen nackten fuß oder nackt
mein fuß nackt einfluss vom
das so schön bei den mono 1 2 lässt wenn
du bist wenn du hast ist mir egal wer da
musst du dir immer die preise kaufen ja
stimmt du weißt ja gar nicht ob ich am
boden als so lange in der mitte ist also
wenn er das nicht gemacht ist dann durch
mehr ernsthaft marke leben leben ich
habe mir ein leben der tafel ja was
willst du dann machen
nicht mal beim du bist nicht mehr leben
relativ traurig irgendwie wie soll ich
das jetzt traurig aber hoch in aktion
oder korea gefallen einfach hoch sätze
sagen allem und jedem training bittet zu
sagen aber erst mal nach oben der alle
hacker ich hab da oben
doch gar nicht wissen organe und dem 5er
reihe das wort zu hängen
vielleicht also ich hab ich hab ja
sowieso runter so betritt macht und
dabei so und zauberer aus der fans kann
ich hab schon erhöht ja und nur weil du
noch nie etwas und es wird es wird
schwierig jetzt lass mich da
die nervensäge
was macht jetzt die jugend ist verboten
ich fühl mich super
ich finde das alles mal hier an
ok also ich bin auch hälfte der herzen
schon direkt nur von runterfallen
vergessen hat der vor diesen verging
bogen als ich heute runterspringen die
in der luft habe es passiert ich bin und
wie habt ihr bestimmt ist und vor allem
im gesprochen gedeckt wurde auf einmal
bei einer runter hier widerspricht töte
dich auf einmal steht der betterplace
und problem dank
das ist schon eine ganze links ganzen
sagen redet die quelle
ja ich habe deine ganzen hick bälle was
auch immer das ok neuen ihren neuen pvp
kind erlebt immer würde
was sollen wir da ist nicht winken pbt
klebt in einer verurteile wieder krieg
ist echt
als ich dann ernst natürlich man das
wohl vergessen dass wir hier spielen
wenn man sagt okay aber wieso findest du
dass wurzeln eine beleidigung
das wollte ich gerade rein kommen
wollten und bei der enns updates
schließen ist nur leider habe ich sein
weil das auch negative konnotation hat
also schwuler wäre keine beleidigung
aber [ __ ] schon da muss man
unterscheiden
ich habe zum planen hast du überhaupt
mit diesem plan dieser liege so barroso
bei mir ist einfach alles super easy und
software dann super easy uns das ist das
was das wird ein kraftakt für den tollen
tipp irgendwie liegt dass immer mehr
leute mit mir aufnehmen dass sie zu
riechen mutanten mutieren ich habe das
gefühl ich mache ich finde das los
willst du hier so spannend wie soll man
weiß auch nicht genau ist du hast also
wahrscheinlich nicht zum reporter
antastet ihr sohn gekauft
und was macht er dann ernst
ok ok spalt sinnvoll vor dass er sein
weil jetzt habe ich zwei wege über die
variieren kann wenn ich pfeifen alter ja
genau sagen nicht so schlecht ist es war
alles taktisch von ihr jetzt schon
wieder hier pause und block ab aber
warum lebst du bei mir mein base mich
bei dir
wenn es wirklich so dass wir christen
die können dann noch länger überleben
ein problem hast ich sag immer recht ihr
problem wie soll da bis jetzt
interpretieren
ich habe ganz einfach gutes zeugen du
hast
ich glaube ja dass bitte sie sich die
zeit zählen ist wird zerstört worden ist
das nicht gut
es war das war echt sehr schnell ein
wunder myself ist nicht so schnell
gemacht geschäft mit ex-meister
irgendwie so ein trick um kisten
schneller abzubauen hause nee das nicht
aber muss nicht immer alles abbauen ich
sags mal so
drei gold noch eine kiste
ich hab es sollte denn noch ist das klo
ribery intense ins kollektive
intelligenz sowie feste gäste das schiff
das natürlich ist praktisch das mit dem
rohbau
dafür angeben dürftest meine sachen gar
nicht nehmen weil das fernglas zu einer
platzsperre
meine mutter hat später wo bist du mama
wo bist du denn schwere musst du bist du
das stört mich es geht ich gar nichts an
wo bist du denn also überall und mögen
die mich so schnell zu mir gekommen
durch ganz gerne müssen so einfach
weggelaufen könnte man so sagen könnte
man aber auch lassen verfügte scheiße
irgendwie habe ich heute so ein bisschen
tod von ok tourette darüber macht sich
also lustig hinein
da hast du wenig ich weiß es keiner gut
treffen
ich habe meine ich jetzt auf brauchen
werden so judith realität was ihr für
mich aber so voll die psychisch einmal
seine ganze irgendeinen psychisch labile
es zeigt die ganze zeit schon sein
leistung minuten überlebt weiß markt das
sind natürlich ganz interessant ist noch
nichts weiß behalten machen keine ahnung
essen kannst du test macht das so
alter wie schnell hast du dir bitte dein
schwert immer das ist nicht mehr schön
gewesen leute ab sofort jeden tag für
festliche stimmung tc esens werden
obwohl das mittel
ach so ja dann ist sehr alles klar wenn
ihr noch mal mein bestes match für mich
sehen wollt sortimo ja oder so hausen
daumen nach oben
3000 44 345 euro geschafft